looks like the romance is keeping steady
between Gigi Hadid and Leonardo DiCaprio
we love it it's great after sparking
dating rumors weeks ago a source tells
E.T Gigi and Leo have been seeing each
other and are very into each other but
Gigi has been trying to keep things
low-key with their relationship yeah
we're definitely getting the hint Gigi
the 27 year old model and the 47 year
old actor have only been spotted out
together a mere couple of times
it's beyond my control so why are they
keeping things so private well our
source tells us the pair is avoiding PDA
to be mindful of Zayn's feelings her ex
whom she shares two-year-old daughter
Kai and Gigi doesn't want to be
disrespectful to him with her new
relationship I think communication and
just knowing you know what the other
person needs and that also comes from
yourself and being able to express that
Gigi and Leo were first seen hanging out
in September during Newark Fashion Week
and things started heating up later that
month when they were spotted in Milan at
the time A source told ET that the two
are the real deal honestly it's
everything I could ever ask for fast
forward to October Gigi and Leo brought
their romance back to the Big Apple when
they attended a Halloween party together
this is a rare sort of occurrence this
is Gigi's first high-profile
relationship since Zane and Leo's first
since his split with Camilla Marone back
in August
while Gigi's keeping her love life under
the radar she's learning how to handle
the pressures of social media something
her mom Yolanda spoke with ET about last
month she doesn't speak very often but
when she speaks she you know she feels
very right she's about it you know but
at the end of the day
you know does it matter so as Gigi finds
new love where do things stand with her
and Zayn our source says they only want
what's best for each other quote they
are doing their best to have a cordial
relationship be the best parents they
can be and co-parent Kai in a healthy
way
[Music]